nacida en 1926
la reina isabel segunda nunca estuvo
destinada a gobernar pero sólo diez años
después cuando su tío eduardo octavo
abdicó por amor su padre jorge sexto
ascendió al trono la princesa heredera
se tomó en serio su nuevo papel
conduciendo una ambulancia para el
ejército británico en la segunda guerra
mundial y entendiendo sus deberes por
venir aire
declaró ante todos ustedes que toda mi
vida sea larga o corta estará dedicada a
su servicio y al de nuestra gran familia
imperial a la que todos pertenecen al
rey
la repentina muerte de su padre hizo que
isabel se convirtiera en reina en
1952 con sólo 25 años al año siguiente
ella y el duque de edimburgo dieron una
vuelta al mundo de seis meses por la
commonwealth incluyendo la primera
visita de un monarca británico a
australia y nueva zelanda ha viajado más
que cualquier otra persona que haya
llevado la corona sin embargo su reinado
ha sido tumultuoso incluyendo el
conflicto norirlandés
varias recesiones y el colapso del
imperio británico en 1992 tres de los
matrimonios de sus hijos dieron paso al
escándalo y el divorcio generando una
gran cantidad de mala publicidad la
muerte de la princesa diana en 1997
provocó una oleada de dolor público la
reina tardó en sumarse pasó una semana
antes de que se dirigiera a la nación y
llega la orden de un dejar las banderas
a media asta
quiero rendir homenaje a diana yo misma
era un ser humano excepcional y dotado
en los buenos y en los malos momentos
nunca perdió su capacidad de sonreír y
amar ni de inspirar a los demás con su
calidez y amabilidad
james con el tiempo la popularidad de la
reina volvió a aumentar miles de
personas llenaron las calles para
celebrar los jubileos de 2002 y 2012 y
el entusiasmo por la realeza aumentó con
los matrimonios de sus nietos y los
nacimientos de sus bisnietos cada vez
más frágil y con recientes brotes de
enfermedad y tras la pérdida de su
marido el duque de edimburgo las
apariciones públicas de la reina son
ahora cada vez más escasas